another essay that is very instructive  that Wilson wrote this is an essay from  1907 an essay called the author and  signers of the Declaration of  Independence Wilson elaborated on this  view of the Declaration and this is what  he said in that document he said we are  not bound to adhere to the doctrines  held by the signers of the Declaration  of Independence we are as free as they  were to make and unmake governments we  are not here to worship man or a  document neither are we here to indulge  in a mere rhetorical and uncritical  eulogy every fourth of July should be a  time for examining our standards our  purposes for determining a fresh what  principles what forms of power we think  most likely to affect our safety and  happiness that in that alone is the  obligation the Declaration lays upon us  so the founding principles themselves  Wilson suggests oblige us to reconsider  in each age what the best government is  for the problems for the circumstances  of that age  mmm